So today we're going to talk about
signaling.
And what we did last week
was kind of a simple example of
signaling and today we're going to do a
more involved application of signaling.
So
what do we mean by signaling? What's the
key idea here?
Well, we're going to look at games where
we have two players.
We have a sender
and a receiver.
And the sender has some private
information.
And then the sender, knowing their
private information, is going to make
some choice about an action. They're
going to then choose an action.
And we we often call this private
information maybe the sender's type.
This is what the sender knows that the
receiver doesn't know.
And then the receiver is going to
observe the action that the sender
chooses, but they're not going to
directly observe the sender's private
information.
So the receiver
observes
the action
but not type. So they see what action
the sender takes, but they can't observe
the private information that the sender
has.
And then based upon that, they're also
going to choose an action.
So in the examples that we're going to
look at,
the receiver
when they're choosing their action,
cares a lot about the sender's private
information.
And the receiver is going to try to
learn or infer
something about the sender's private
information based upon the action that
the sender chooses.
And conversely, the sender cares a lot
about what the receiver believes about
them.
And the sender is going to try to convey
information about their private
information through their choice of
action. Now that's a bit abstract, so
let's think of some examples.
I don't know if any of you
come across, heard of the term signaling
used colloquially and heard of examples
where this
this term is applied.
So a few examples. I guess a classic one
would be luxury goods.
Right. So here the story would be that
the private information that the sender
has, their type, is maybe how rich they
are, right? How much money they have.
The action they're choosing is, you
know, what brand of bag to buy.
The receiver then
doesn't directly know how rich the
sender is, but they do observe what
brand of item they choose.
And the receiver is going to make an
inference about how rich the person is
based upon how luxurious the item is
that they hold.
And the sender
wanting to be perceived as rich will
then choose to buy something luxurious,
right? Now, why does this work? Well,
your concern might be, well look, if
everyone wants to be perceived as rich,
why doesn't everyone just buy the luxury
item?
And the issue is that well, they're
expensive and only some people can
afford them. So a crucial aspect for
these signals to be credible is that the
action people are taking is generally
going to have a different cost depending
on their private information. If
everyone was able to buy luxury items
cuz they were so cheap, that wouldn't
credibly convey that I was wealthy. But
for a very expensive item because only
sufficiently wealthy people can buy it,
that's going to be conveying
information. Another classic story from
kind of the animal world, I guess, is a
peacock's feathers.
Any ideas about what's being conveyed
here and what's the role of the
the peacock's feathers?
Why do peacocks grow very very
ostentatious, large feathers? Well, it's
not because people really care about the
feathers. The idea would be that this is
a signal of health. So if we if we map
this into our example, the sender, one
peacock, privately has private
information about how healthy they are.
They're trying to attract maybe a mate.
And the mate cares about how healthy the
peacock is. If the health if the peacock
grows these enormous feathers, that's
extremely costly. It takes a lot of
energy. You have to
you know, to grow this. So by growing
very very large, ostentatious feathers,
they're conveying to the receiver that I
must be very very healthy, right? And
the receiver doesn't directly care about
the feathers, they just care about
underlying health and the feathers
provide a signal of that.
One classic example which we'll go
through today would be
college.
So this is sort of a classic signaling
application.
How does college fit into this
sender
receiver
model or how could it?
Yeah? Show a job
recruiter that you are smart.
Right, exactly. So here your private
information might be how smart you are,
how diligent you are, how hard working
you are. We can have various kind of
positive attributes.
You're choosing whether to go to some
difficult
university and get some demanding
degree.
The receiver might directly care about
what you learn in your degree, but they
might not.
It might be that your degree is actually
not that relevant for what you're doing
on the job, but they care about your
degree because it's a signal of how
smart you are. The idea would be that
some people are able to get this degree
and pass and other people are not and
therefore your ability to get this
degree and take this action reveals
information
um
about your ability.
So
let's dig in a little bit deeper into
this college
example cuz that's going to be kind of
the main application we're going to look
at today. And this is often goes under
the name of job market signaling.
SO THIS WAS INTRODUCED IN THIS FAMOUS
PAPER by Michael Spence
in 1973. I think it was actually maybe
his PhD dissertation and he ultimately
won the Nobel Prize for for this idea
which we might go over today and you
might say it's pretty simple. How did he
get the Nobel Prize for that? But I
think things after the fact seem simple,
but coming up with them is often quite
difficult.
So let's
just observe some facts about the world,
about college education. There's
something called the college wage
premium.
And this refers to the fact that at
least all of the world, but let's focus
on the United States, people who go to
college or complete a college degree
tend to earn more than people who don't.
And this is something labor economists
study a lot and try to give different
estimates. You'll see a lot of estimates
floating around depending on how they
measure it or which cohort or which kind
of person they're looking at, but maybe
a rough estimate in the US might be
something like maybe 500k to a million
is maybe kind of the middle of the road
estimates and this is in lifetime
earnings.
So what do I mean by this? I mean if you
just look at people in the US, you look
at those who have college degrees
and you compute the average earnings of
those people who have college degrees
and then you look at people who don't
have college degrees and you look at the
average earnings of those people over
their lifetime and you compare it, you
see that people who go to college on
average earn maybe 500k to a million
dollars more over their lifetime.
As I said, there's a few different
estimates about this. Now, the question
is why?
Any thoughts about
why this is? Why do people who go to
college earn more?
You're here at college. Maybe you partly
want to earn more by coming to college.
Any thoughts about why this is?
So maybe there's we often separate this
into kind of two different stories. So
one is what we might call a causal
story.
I'll just say causal. We don't
necessarily have to put the word story.
So is it causal? Why is it causal? What
I mean is, let's look at someone who
doesn't go to college.
If they chose to instead go to college,
would their earnings go up?
That would mean it's causal.
Or maybe it's not causal.
Maybe someone who doesn't go to college,
if they did go to college, wouldn't
actually increase their earnings.
Now I think a lot of people would look
at this fact and just immediately say,
oh it must be causal. If you if going to
college if people who go to college earn
more, then it must be that if I choose
to go to college, that's going to
increase my earnings. And this is kind
of a classic fallacy,
a potential fallacy when people haven't
thought so carefully about this data.
And that's possible. It could be causal,
but one explanation is not causal. How
could that be? How could it be that
people who go to college earn more
money, yet
going to college wouldn't actually
increase my earning. How could that How
could that story make sense?
Well, the story here would be that well,
the people who go to college are very
different from the people who don't go
to college. You have two pools of
people. You have people who go to
college and people who don't. People who
go to college are just smarter, more
ambitious on average or have some other
trait that is hard to measure.
They're they do earn more, but it's not
because they go to college. They just
happen to be going to college. And this
is a I guess the classic story of this.
This is a problem with all these health
studies where they say, you know, people
who eat five almonds a day live five
years longer.
Eating five almonds a day doesn't make
you live five years longer, but people
who eat almonds are different in a lot
of different ways. They eat healthily in
other ways, they run, they exercise,
they do all these other things. So it
could be that
um
though there's a big earnings gap, it's
not because you go to college, it's just
a spurious correlation. So that's one
one potential explanation.
Another would be that it's that it is
causal. That if I as an individual
choose to go to college, that's going to
increase my expected earning.
And I think the best evidence suggests
that both there's an element of both of
these at play. There's maybe this we
might call selection.
The people who who go to college are a
selected group. They're different on
average than people who don't go to
college. And you know, I I frame this as
causal versus not causal. I think the
best evidence suggests it's a bit of
both. That when we look at this earning
gap between people who go to college and
people who don't, partly it's
attributable to selection. Those people
just have different skills and partly
it's a causal effect of college. But I
want to drill down within causal. And I
think there's actually two different
mechanisms that could be at work here.
So So let's focus on the causal
component. Let's just suppose that it is
true that if I go to college my earnings
go up.
Okay? Why might that be the case?
Why might going to college cause me to
earn more?
Yeah. Well, you're able to learn skills
that like you can quantify later. Great.
So the
certainly the story that people who run
colleges would would like to focus on is
this story, right? That it's about
learning skills.
Sometimes this is called human capital
formation. That you go to school, you
learn how to you know, code, you learn
how to communicate with people, you
learn knowledge information about the
world, you mature, various things, and
these make you a more valuable employee.
They allow you to be more productive. So
this is sometimes we talk about this
might be about productivity.
But another possibility, which is we're
going to focus on today, learning
is
signaling.
So the other possibility could be that
it is causal.
Going to college makes me earn more. But
it's not because I actually learn
anything valuable in college. It's
simply because going to college proves
to the employer that I'm smart.
And therefore the employer pays me more.
It's still causal. If I didn't go to
college, I wouldn't earn as much. So it
is true that going to college changes my
expected earnings. But it changes it not
because of actually acquired valuable
skills, but because I've demonstrated
that I could do a very difficult task.
And that makes employers want to hire
me. So one way of separating this, you
know, you could imagine that
um
a school, you know, in kind of the
extreme case you could imagine a school
that teaches skills that really have no
value, but are just really really hard
to learn.
Uh and you might imagine just people who
graduate from that school might actually
uh still do well in the workforce. And
maybe an example of that, I mean, I
don't want to uh I think athletics are a
valuable pursuit, but you might think
that people who succeed in athletics are
often hired by firms to work in finance,
say. Um it's not that being good at
running makes you or being good at
weightlifting makes you better at
finance, but it shows that you've done
something very hard that reveals
something maybe about your diligence,
your work ethic. And that might be uh a
reason why uh firms want to hire you.
So in reality I think both are probably
present. And I think the best empirical
evidence at the moment suggests both of
these mechanisms are at play. But to to
highlight the signaling aspect, we're
going to focus all in on signaling. And
we're going to consider a model of
education where education conveys no
valuable skills. I want to say up front,
this is not my view of how what of
education, but uh just to highlight this
not I think we all understand how
learning skills increases your wage. I
think this is sort of the novel element
of Spence's model and uh and this is
what we want to look at. And I will say
there are people who argue that this is
almost all of education. Uh
it's a debate, but there are some people
who say this is really all that's what's
going on. So let's uh let's go through
this.
So one, I'll just maybe make one
observation. One way that people try to
argue it's all about signaling. Uh one
kind of interesting empirical test is
they look at people who go to college
for like 3 and 1/2 years and then drop
out.
Now if it's really about skills, you
think somebody who goes for 3 and 1/2
years has acquired almost all of the
skills as somebody who goes for 4 years.
But if it's about signaling, you might
think, well, the fact that they dropped
out reveals a lot about who they are as
a person. And indeed people who drop out
just before graduating earn a lot less.
And that's one argument for why
signaling is at play, but you know, we
can debate about these things. Okay. So
now let's go through our formal model of
signaling.
So in our model we're going to have a
sender
and a receiver just as I said before.
And we're really going to simplify
things. We're going to imagine the
sender just has two types.
They privately know their type T
which
is either L or H. They're either a low
type or a high type.
And
you know,
we're going to think of this maybe we
can think of this a bit abstractly, but
a low type is someone who is uh going to
find education more costly and a high
type is going to find education less
costly. We can interpret this in a lot
of ways. It could be about your
intelligence, it could be about your
work ethic, it could be about uh the
quality of the school you went to
before. There's a lot of things that
could go into this. Um but we're just
going to kind of quite abstractly call
it a low type uh and a high type.
And
what they're going to choose
is they're going to choose a level of
education.
And in reality education kind of usually
comes in in units. Like you can't we
don't really think you get, you know,
862 days of education. We usually think
you either get graduate high school or
you graduate college. But to make things
simple, we're going to make education
continuous, E. And we're just going to
say it's a number between 0 and 1. So
you can sort of think of this
um
you know, just this a stylized uh model
where you can sort of get any continuous
amount of education. This could be
something like uh the fraction of
uh I don't know, your life you spend
being educated or something.
Now the receiver
we're going to think of this as maybe a
firm
or kind of a market
of firms.
And they're going to observe
E but not T.
Right? When a firm chooses to hire you,
they see what education you got. They
don't directly observe this type T,
whether you're low or high type person.
And then they're going to choose a wage.
You know, in reality I think a lot of
individual firms
the wage is roughly set and they're
choosing whether to hire you or not.
There's maybe some flexibility over
wages. But that's one way we can think
of I think it's helpful to think of this
kind of as a market. So it may be that
each individual firm is making a binary
choice about whether to hire you. But
then you go to the firm that gives you
the best offer. So in the end the job
the outcome of the of the firm of the
labor market is that you get hired at
some place for some wage. And depending
on how well you do, that wage is kind of
determined by which firm hires you.
Okay? So now let's talk about payoffs.
So we're going to assume the sender
their payoffs are
like this.
So the sender wants to get paid more.
Their payoff is their utility is
increasing in their wage. They don't
like going to school. Again, another
maybe stylized assumption. Some people
enjoy going to school and that's why
they go. Uh but we're not going to have
that in our model. We're going to assume
that people just don't like school. And
notice the more they get educated, the
more costly it is. So they'd always
rather have less school than more
school, other things being equal.
But now their type T appears in the
denominator here. And maybe I should be
more precise. Here we have
B. Unnatural if you did any other way,
the low type is lower than the high
type.
So by putting T in the denominator here,
what I mean is if you're a high type, if
T is higher, then the coefficient in
front of this cost is lower.
And therefore the cost, or more
importantly the marginal cost of
education is lower for the high type.
Uh why might that be true? Well, maybe
they don't have to study as hard uh to
get into the school. Maybe once they get
in it's easier for them to get good
grades and graduate. There's many
stories we can tell. Um but again, we're
going to sort of think of your type as
representing how costly it is for you to
get education.
And then the receiver, we're going to
use a bit of a weird payoff
specification.
The receiver's utility is going to be
like this.
Now this may at first seem a bit
strange. What we're saying is the
receiver's utility is the negative of
the difference between the wage they
actually charge and the type of the
applicant of the sender.
And really the the reason we make that
assumption is the implication of this is
that the optimal wage
W is equal to
the expectation of T.
And this is just a algebraic fact about
the quadratic loss function. You can
check this with algebra. So if I don't
know what T is, with some probability
it's low, with some probability it's
high.
The optimal wage for me to set
is exactly my expectation of T. So if I
know the person is low ability, it's
optimal for me to set a wage of L. If I
know they're a high type H, it's optimal
for me to set a wage of H. And if I
think it's, say, 50/50, then I want to
pay them exactly half L plus half H.
Now you might say, "Wait a second,
that's not what firms do. They pay the
lowest wage they can subject to getting
the worker."
But again, we can think of this as kind
of the outcome of competition. So if
there's many firms competing, uh if I
charge or if I pay a worker less than
their expected ability, then um maybe
I'm going to lose that lose out to
another firm and the other firm is going
to hire them. If I pay them more than
their expected ability, then I'm
overpaying them. So uh we can think of
this as a reduced form representation of
kind of a competitive labor market.
And I should say something about the
prior here. Let's assume that H occurs
with probability pi and L with 1 minus
pi.
So in the population
fraction pi of people are of type H or
the high types and fraction 1 minus pi
of people are at the low types.
Okay. So now we're ready to analyze this
game.
And
the first step is always to write down
what a strategy is.
Notice this game is a little more
complicated than what we looked at
before because now education is
something continuous. Before in the
class on Thursday we looked at this this
problem where you chose whether to
submit an essay or not. And that was a
binary choice. I'll make one other
observation. Last Thursday we looked at
something where your private type
affected how much you wanted to get into
a school, but not how costly it was to
submit an essay.
Now we're doing an opposite assumption
where your type doesn't affect how much
you want to get paid. Everyone wants to
get paid more, but your type only
affects how costly it is for you to get
educated. So, it's kind of the inverse
of what we did last week. And I think
this is probably
uh a pretty good model of the labor
market where
at you know, most people want more wage
higher wages. Uh that's not really what
distinguishes them.
Okay. So, what is a a strategy or more
precisely, what is an assessment?
So, remember an assessment is a strategy
profile together with a belief system.
So, we need to first say, let's look at
the sender strategy.
What is the strategy for the sender?
Well, the sender chooses an action, a
level of education after knowing or
learning their private type T.
So, we need to specify what education
the sender chooses when they're the low
type and what education they choose when
they're the high type. So, we'll
represent a sender's strategy as EL,
EH. It's two numbers.
EL says, if you're low type sender, this
is how much I'm going to education I'm
going to get. EH says, if I'm a high
type uh sender, this is how much
education I'm going to get.
And yeah, I say sender, you know, you
can think of this as the the student.
Okay, what about the What is the
strategy for the receiver?
This is a bit harder.
Well, remember a strategy is always a
complete contingent plan. It says, what
action do you take as a function of what
you observe?
So, in this case, the receiver observes
your level of education and they're
going to choose what wage they set as a
function of your education. So,
formally, the receiver is choosing a
function W
from 0 1
maybe I'll say to
0 infinity.
So, what this says
is it assigns to each level of education
E a wage W of E that
that the receiver or firm will pay you
if they observe that your education
level is E.
And they have to do that for every
single education level uh in 0 1.
So, that describes the strategy profile,
but we're not done yet because an
assessment also specifies beliefs. So,
now we also have to specify a belief
system.
Well,
the sender already knows their type. So,
we don't need to say anything about the
sender's type.
We have to specify the receiver's
beliefs about the sender's type.
And once again, the receiver might learn
about the sender's type through the
level of education E.
So, a belief system is going to say,
what do I as the firm believe about you
as a function of what education I see?
If I see that you got a lot of
education, what do I believe about your
ability? If I see that you didn't get
very much education, what do I believe
about your ability? So, a belief system
formally
uh maybe if we write it, let's start
formally and then we'll be a little less
formal.
So, if we're formal about it, a belief
system says for every level of education
I see
I'm going to form a belief, which is a
probability distribution over your
ability, either L or H. So, the notation
here just means this is the set of
probability distributions over your
ability being L and your ability being
H.
But,
we can specify a probability
distribution here just by saying, what
do I think is the probability that
you're a high type? Because once we
specify the probability you're high
type, then the probability that you're
low type is just one minus that, right?
So, we're going to think of this
maybe we'll write
BHE.
So, we'll just use this notation
and this says, if I see that your
education is E, this is the probability
that I think you're a high type.
And that fully specifies my beliefs
because the probability that I think
you're a low type is always one minus
that. So, maybe I'll just write that
because BL given E
the probability that I assign to you
being a low type given E is just one
minus
BHE.
So, technically, we have to specify both
of these things, but we're only going to
specify one of them because it the uh
it's pinned down by the other.
Okay?
Great.
So, now we have to fill all these things
in.
We have to specify the sender strategy
the receiver strategy and then the
belief system, which is a system of
beliefs for the receiver. Any questions
on this?
Okay.
Now, what do we need to check?
So, now we're going to look at our
equilibrium conditions.
And remember, we're looking for the
conditions and these are for PBE.
Our equilibrium notion is perfect
Bayesian equilibrium.
And we have kind of three conditions or
depending on how you write it. One is
sequential optimality or sequential
rationality.
You might see both terms used,
sequential optimality, sequential
rationality, they mean the same thing.
And then belief consistency.
And it's helpful to separate this into
sequential optimality for the sender and
also for the receiver.
So, let's first just say what each of
these things
mean in words.
Uh
Sequential optimality for the sender
just means, if I'm the sender
and I know my type T
my equilibrium level of education is
optimal for me given what everything
else that's happening in the game.
So, for the sender, this means
for each T
where remember T is my type and it could
be either low ability or high ability.
So, for each T, if my type is T
choosing ET
remember this could either be EL or EH
depending on the value of T is optimal
given W.
Remember, what is W here? W is the wage
that the receiver sets.
And which education level is optimal for
me depends on W.
Because when I'm thinking, what if I go
to school a little bit less or a little
bit more, what if I deviate? Well, to
see whether that's worth it, I have to
trade off the cost of say additional
education against the effect that would
have on my wage.
And that's going to be governed by the
strategy W that the receiver uses. So,
that's going to be relevant in
determining whether ET is optimal.
And then for the receiver
well,
with the receiver, this is actually
we can write this maybe a bit more
easily. So,
for each E
and E is in 0 1
the receiver's wage must be optimal
given their beliefs. So, we need
choosing
W of E
is optimal
given
BHE.
So, what we're saying is I'm the
receiver, I observe an education level E
that causes me to form beliefs BHE
about your type
and given those beliefs, the wage that I
actually choose as the receiver is
optimal.
Okay?
Can we write that out in math? I mean,
given what we said above
we said that it's always optimal given
my quadratic loss utility to always
charge a wage equal to my
updated expectation about your type.
So, can we write this condition
in words? What does it mean for W of E
to be optimal given B of H
given E?
What must W of E be?
Yeah. Expected value of T.
Okay, and and and how can we write that
in terms of B of H given E?
Um
So, you're you're right. Uh
Well, H and L
are the numbers, so then the L type or
Oh, is it H times B of H plus
L times I guess 1 minus B? Exactly
right. Yeah. So, indeed, it is the
expectation of T, but we have to be
careful because our expectation of T is
influenced by the education we see and
our beliefs, right? So, it's not just
our prior expectation. And maybe I
should be clear here
when I write this, this is the, you
know, updated expectation.
This is the expectation of T that
reflects the new information that I have
uh given your educational choice. And
indeed,
if seeing E causes me to believe that
this is the probability that you're a
high type and one minus that is the
probability that you're a low type,
well, now I can compute the expected
value of your type. And yeah, I should
emphasize here that L and H are actually
numbers, right? Sometimes we think of
high type and low type as just labels,
but here a low type is like 0.7 and a
high type is like 2.3 and these these
numbers actually have meaning.
Um okay. So, indeed, we get H times
B of H given E plus L times Well, we
could write B of L given E, but using
the notation we're using, we'll just
write 1 minus B of H given E.
Okay?
So, that's pretty easy to write down.
And now belief consistency.
>> [clears throat]
>> Well,
remember belief consistency says the
receiver has to be applying Bayes rule
wherever possible.
And the receiver can only apply Bayes
rule when they see a level of education
that someone is actually supposed to
choose with positive probability.
So,
we can sort of separate Sometimes this
is called on path
and off path.
Same prime.
So, if they see an education level E
that's on path, meaning that either the
low type or the high type is supposed to
choose this with positive probability
under their equilibrium strategy, then
we apply Bayes rule.
But if we see an off path education, we
see a level of education that is not
supposed to be chosen by either type,
um
and
then
there are no restrictions.
Let's be a bit more precise here. Which
education levels are on path given the
strategy that we've written down for the
sender? Well, there's only two that are
on path. It's exactly the numbers EL and
EH. Those are the only two education
levels that the receiver expects to see
in equilibrium. So, these are precisely
the cases where E is either EL or EH.
If the sender was using a mixed
strategy, this would be a bit more
complicated. There may be more education
levels they might choose. But I as the
receiver know that well,
if you're low type, you're supposed to
choose this education level. If you're
high type, you're supposed to choose
this education level. And if I see any
other education level, well, I wasn't
supposed to see this in equilibrium, so
I'm not able to apply Bayes rule. Of
course, this is quite a simplification.
In reality, we see a lot of education
levels. People's types are not binary
and we'll we'll do extensions later, but
for now this is uh
we are.
And then we have E is not
an element of
EL and EH.
Okay.
So, to kind of start dealing with Bayes
rule, it turns out that it's helpful to
distinguish
two different kinds of equilibria, and
that's what we're going to look at now.
So, we're going to
consider two kinds of equilibria.
What are called separating equilibria
and a pooling equilibrium.
So, what defines a separating
equilibrium
is that EL
is not equal to EH.
So, what let's think through this. What
does this mean? What does the receiver
learn
if we're in an equilibrium where the low
type chooses one education level and the
high type chooses a different education
level? What can the receiver conclude
when they see the sender's education
level? What do they learn?
Well, they perfectly learn the sender's
type, right? Because in a separating
equilibrium,
the implication of that
Let's write it this way.
If I'm the receiver and I see that you
chose a high level that you chose EH,
I know for certain that you must be a
high type.
And conversely zero here.
Why? Well, if I see EH, the low type
never chooses EH. They always choose a
different education level EL. So, if I
see EH, I know that you must be a high
type and therefore I assign probability
one to you being a high type.
Conversely, if I see a low education
level,
then I know that the only kind of person
who would choose a low level of
education, at least in this equilibrium,
is the low type. So, I assign zero
probability to being the high type.
And then what about B of H given E for
all other E?
What about for E that aren't equal to EL
or EH?
Well, there's no restriction on these.
So, these are unconstrained and we'll
fill these in as we as we want, but this
is going to be unconstrained.
Okay, now look at let's look at the
pooling equilibrium
where EL equals EH.
And sometimes it's nice to give a label
to this.
Um so, let's call this E star.
So, here both the high types and the low
types choose the same level of
education, E star.
So, now
what is B of H given E star?
Well, if everyone choose the same level
of education,
their choice of education hasn't
revealed any new information to me.
So, my belief about them should be the
same that it was
the same as my prior.
And my prior belief was pi that they
were high ability, right? So, this must
be pi.
Um
because
I mean, you could write out Bayes rule,
but I think the basic idea is if I
thought that the probability you're high
ability was pi and then I know that
whoever you are, you're going to choose
the education level E star, then the
fact that you chose E star doesn't give
me any new information about your
ability. So, it's this must still be pi.
And then again,
we have flexibility
is unconstrained
for all other E.
And
part of constructing equilibria is going
to sort of to be to think a little bit
about a bit about what those beliefs
have to be.
So, let's start with pooling. I think
pooling is actually an easier case, so
let's let's start there.
So, let's try to construct our
equilibrium. So,
case one is the pooling equilibrium.
Okay?
And
for the sender, we know that they're
choosing
EL equals EH equals E star.
And we're going to try to solve for this
value of E star, but we're just going to
put it in as a placeholder for now.
And now let's look at the receiver.
The receiver needs to choose W of E.
Let's sort of think through as the
analyst what we want to do here. We're
trying to construct an equilibrium
where both the low type and the high
type choose this education level E star.
And now we're going to try to choose
what this wage is to make E star optimal
for the sender. So, any ideas about
what might be Well,
let's think a little bit about this
wage.
Let's separate into two cases.
What does W of E star have to be?
I argue that if we're look we're looking
for an equilibrium where
both the low type and the high type pool
on this education level E star.
And now we're going to try to fill in in
this equilibrium what the receiver's
wage strategy is. And I argue that here
we basically know what it has to be by
the combination of
belief consistency and sequential
optimality.
Well, we know what the beliefs are here.
We just said the beliefs are that your
ability is high with probability pi.
And if those are our beliefs, well, over
where did we write it? Here, we said if
those are your beliefs, we computed what
the wage has to be.
So, let's plug in pi for this
and 1 minus pi for this.
Uh and indeed, we get that this is H
times pi
plus L
times 1 minus pi.
So, that's pinned down.
And I think this is sort of a key
observation when analyzing these
signaling games.
The question is
I said that your beliefs off path are
unconstrained. So, if you observe when
the receiver observes a level of
education that's different from E star,
we can fill in whatever beliefs we want
for that kind of receiver.
But we can't fill in whatever wage we
want.
What what is the range of wages we could
possibly put in here that would be
consistent with
receiver optimality?
How high or high low how low could these
wages be?
Well, what's the most pessimistic belief
the receiver could form?
What's the worst belief they could have
about the
uh sender? They could think you're
certainly a low type.
And if they think you're certainly a low
type, what is the optimal wage to
charge?
Just L, right? And if they think you're
certainly a high type, then the optimal
wage is H.
And any belief they form is going to
make it so that the optimal wage for
them is going to be somewhere between L
and H. It can't be lower than L because
there's no belief that would make the
expectation lower than L. It can't be
higher than H cuz there's no belief that
would make the wage the optimal wage
higher than H, but we can actually
choose anything
between L and H.
Because whatever choice we make between
L and H, we can then construct some
belief that justifies that wage choice.
So,
let's try to think this through.
If you're trying to construct
a wage that makes we want to make this
an equilibrium.
So, let's maybe think of it graphing it
down here.
Here's E star.
Here's our wage W.
The wage here is pinned down
to be this. Maybe I'll give notation for
this. Uh
I'll just write it down. I'll just
That's here.
And now the question is
what choices of wage should we make off
path
to ensure that the sender actually wants
to choose an education level of E star?
So, here we're trying to construct an
equilibrium. We don't want the sender to
have any profitable deviations.
So, any ideas about what what wage we
would set off path
to encourage the sender to choose this
ed- education level E star?
Well, this is What's the sender tempted
to do? They're supposed to choose E star
in equilibrium. They're tempted to
choose a lower level of education cuz if
they choose a lower level of education,
that's less costly for them.
So, the only way to make sure that
that's not a profitable deviation is to
say, "Well, if you choose any less
education, your wage is going to drop a
lot."
And let's look at the extreme case where
the wage drops all the way
to L.
So, we're going to think of a wage
function that says, "If you don't get
enough education E star,
you're going to get paid a very low wage
of L.
But if you go to college, if you achieve
this certification, if you go to school
for long enough, now you can get a job
that pays a higher wage of this.
And then what happens if E is even
higher than that? Well, we don't we want
to make sure that no one wants to get
even more education than necessary. So,
we might as well just keep the wage
flat.
And if we keep the wage flat, then we
know that well, if someone can get the
same wage by choosing E star as choosing
a higher level of education,
they would never pay more to get an even
higher level of education if the wage
that they're going to get is exactly the
same.
So, this is I think a good conjecture
for what this uh equilibrium might be.
So, let's write this out more formally.
What we have is W of E
equals L
if E is less than E star.
Strictly less than E star.
And it's
H pi
plus L 1 minus pi.
And then
if we wanted to
fill in beliefs, let's just be really
precise.
Our beliefs are well, if E is less than
E star, the firm charges
pays a wage of of L. The only way it's
optimal for them to charge a wage of L
is if they believe you're certain to be
a low type.
So, we must have zero here.
And then if they see a level of
education that's at least E star,
they're paying exactly this wage. So,
what must their belief be if they see a
level of education at least E star to
make that wage optimal given their
belief?
Yeah.
Let's think. If if you're a high type,
what's the optimal wage?
Oh.
If I know you're high type, now my
optimal wage is H.
But the optimal but the wage they're
charging is this, right?
Which is H times pi plus L times 1 minus
pi. So, I need to find the belief that
makes my expected so that makes the
expected type equal to this, right?
Pi, exactly.
If I ever if there was some education
level that made me believe you're a high
type, then I I I'd want to charge you a
high wage there, and now there might be
a deviation because now someone would
want to get that education to prove that
they're a high type, right? So, let's
kind of think through what's happening
here.
The firms are saying, "Look,
there's some minimal education level E
star that you need to get. If you get
less than that education level, I don't
think you're very high ability. I think
you're certain to be low ability, and
I'm going to charge you a low a low a
low wage, namely L.
But if you get enough education, let's
say you graduate from college, then I'm
going to form a more optimistic belief
about you. I'm going to believe that
you're uh just like anyone from the
population, you're a high type with
probability pi, and you're a low type
with probability 1 minus pi, and because
I believe that,
I'm going to charge you a wage that's uh
equal to this.
So, we have kind of this two-tiered wage
system where if you graduate from
college, you get a wage premium, but at
least in this equilibrium, further
education doesn't further increase your
wage. And that's consistent with some
settings. We could also construct other
equilibria. But we're not quite done
yet.
We're going to have to be careful about
the value of E star to actually make
this an equilibrium.
So, let's check let's see what what
we've chosen, what we've satisfied here.
Belief consistency
is good because the only time belief
consistency has any bite here is when E
equals E star. That's the only on-path
level of education, and we're consistent
with Bayes' rule. So, we're good with
belief consistency.
And by construction, the receiver is
always paying the wage that's equal to
their updated expectation of the
sender's type.
So, we're good for the receiver. The one
thing we still have to check is sender
optimality.
So,
what could go wrong
in this equilibrium?
What could How could sender optimality
potentially be violated if we choose E
star wrong?
Well,
the problem is
if E star is really really big,
I might say, "Look, yes, I get a higher
wage
if I get at least E star of education,
but that education is so costly to me
that it's not worth me going to school
to get that higher wage."
So, we need to check that E star is
intuitively E star is going to have to
be low enough that it's actually
worthwhile for people to go to college,
right? Just cuz there's a college wage
premium,
if the college wage premium is smaller
than the cost of education, people
aren't going to go. And in fact, if we
look over here,
the college wage premium is not too far
from the cost of education, right? So,
that is that is an issue. We have to
make sure that the wage premium exceeds
the cost of education. So, we have a
final condition here. So, we need to it
remains to check uh sender optimality.
So, at first it's tricky. We have to say
for both types T equals L and H,
choosing E star
is better
than any other
education E in 0 1.
Okay?
Now, this is a hard condition because it
has to hold for both types,
and we're comparing E star to any other
level of education. And there's
infinitely many other levels of
education someone might choose.
So, the key to simplifying things is to
say, "Well, instead of saying it's
better than any other education,
let's try to find
the best deviation."
Right? I could deviate from E star to
anything, and we have to make sure that
I don't want to deviate from E star to
any other level of education.
But some of these other levels of
education, it's clear that I'm never
going to choose. So, let's focus on the
most attractive deviation, and as long
as the most attractive deviation is not
profitable, then no other deviation can
be profitable either.
So, if I'm looking at this wage chart,
this is the wage function I'm facing,
and I'm choosing how much education to
get.
I'm already here at E star.
What would be the most attractive
deviation? I'm not saying it's
profitable, but if I'm going to deviate,
how should I deviate?
What's the the best possible deviation
rate? Yeah?
Zero is the only one that has a chance,
right? Because clearly
deviating above E star doesn't make any
sense because I'm paying more in
education, and I'm not getting any wage
benefit.
So, the only deviation that could be
profitable
and I should put best in parentheses.
It could be that Yeah, anyway.
Um
if I
So, I don't want to choose any education
higher than E star.
If I choose education strictly below E
star, well, my wage is the same no
matter what education I choose.
So, since I hate school according to the
the
I might as well choose the lowest
possible level of education. So, the
only thing we have to check is a
deviation of
E equals 0.
Okay?
And now we have to check that
both for the high type and for the low
type. So, let's write down the two
conditions we need.
So,
let's look at T equals L and T equals H.
We want to compare what utility will
that person get if they choose E star
versus 0. So, if they choose E star,
their utility is going to be
uh
I really need notation for this.
Uh
Let me call this prior mean. Let me call
this uh mu.
As mu for mean, okay? So, let me use
just call that mu.
So, if I choose um
E star, I get a wage of mu
minus 1 over L
E star
squared.
And that must be better
than
L.
Maybe
just so we see what's going on here.
Okay? This is the key condition. Let's
go over it slowly.
I'm a type L.
If I do what I'm supposed to do, I get
paid a wage of mu.
I choose a level of education E star.
My cost of that education is 1 over L
times E star squared. That comes from uh
the formula for my utility up here. And
we plugged in for my wage you mu because
that's the wage I get if I choose E
star. Right? So, let's remind ourselves
here. This is W of E star.
If instead I choose zero education,
well, my wage is L
because
we see over here and maybe I'll
write that down here. This is W of zero.
This is the wage that's offered to me if
I choose no education.
And if I choose no education, this is
the cost.
But this cost is just zero because if I
choose no education, the cost is zero.
So, we don't even have to worry about
this term. Zero squared is zero. I can
just cross this out.
And now let's go down to L equals H and
write down the same formula.
Now, I think a lot of people are tempted
to put an H on the right-hand side.
But that's not correct cuz remember,
what is L representing? L is the wage
the firm charges if you get no
education.
If I deviate and get no education, I'm
offered a wage of L whether I'm a high
type or a low type. So, this is coming
from W of zero. It's not about my true
type, it's about what the firm is
actually doing.
So, here's here are the
two conditions we have.
And we need both of them to hold.
It turns out one of these conditions is
going to be
more
demanding than the other. Which of these
is
harder to satisfy?
We have two inequalities. Yeah? Uh the
one on top. Okay, and why? Because the 1
over L times E star squared term is
greater than the 1 over H times E star
squared term. Exactly right. So, because
L is smaller, 1 over L is bigger. So,
we're subtracting a bigger number and
that's harder to satisfy. And this makes
sense. Let's think about what each of
these inequalities say.
If we move these things around, what
we're exactly saying is
let's think of moving the cost to this
side and subtracting L on this side,
right? Let me kind of write that down
here. This is sort of the key condition.
So, the key condition is mu minus L
is greater than or equal to
1 over L
E star squared. And this I think has a
very natural interpretation.
Mu minus L is the quote unquote college
wage premium.
This is the difference in wage I get if
I choose an education level of E star
versus an education level of zero.
Because if I choose E star, I get mu. If
I choose zero, I get L.
So, this is the wage premium. And this
condition says the wage premium is
higher than the cost of education.
And indeed, it's worth it for me to go
to college if the wage premium I get
from going to college, that is the
additional wage I get from going to
college, more than outweighs the cost I
have to bear of going to college.
Now, we also need to check that the wage
premium exceeds the cost of education
for the high type.
But for the high type, going to college
is is less costly.
So, as long as we check that the wage
premium is worth it for the low type,
well, it's certainly going to be worth
it for the high type because they get
the same wage premium, but they find
education less costly. And that's
exactly the the observation that was
made at the end.
So, this is our equilibrium condition.
And as long as this is satisfied, then
this is indeed going to be an
equilibrium.
So, we actually have constructed many
different equilibria
parameterized by this level E star.
There could be an equilibrium where we
say, if you go to school for 0.3, for E
equals 0.3, then you get a high wage.
There could also be an equilibrium where
if you go to school for 0.4, you get a
high wage. And these are both
conceivable equilibria uh and there's a
huge range of equilibria that we can
construct.
Any questions on on this?
Okay, so now
let's look for a pooling uh let's look
for a separating equilibrium. So, so far
we've just done pooling.
Let's look for maybe a separating
equilibrium.
Now, let's look for a separating
So, what that means is we have E L
is not equal
to E H. So, instead of just solving for
E star, we have to solve for E L and E
H.
Uh and now
let's try to think of what W is going to
have to be.
So, I think, you know, on a problem set,
if you're trying to construct an
equilibrium, it's always very helpful to
separate
what the firm or what the receiver does
on path from what the receiver does off
path.
Because on path, Bayes' rule applies and
we really have precise control over what
the wage has to be.
Off path, Bayes' rule can't be applied
because we divide by zero when we apply
Bayes' rule and we have a lot of
flexibility in what this wage is.
Uh okay.
So,
if we're looking for an equilibrium, a
separating equilibrium, with these two
levels of education E H and E L, what is
the firm's wage going to have to be if
they see an education level of E L?
Or maybe the first question is what is
their belief going to have to be and
then what is their wage going to have to
be?
Well, what do they learn if they see
someone choose an education level E L?
They learn that they must be a low type,
right? Because the high types always
choose E H. Notice this is a key
difference with a pooling equilibrium.
If all the types choose the same level
of education, I don't learn about your
type by seeing your education level.
But if different types choose different
levels of education, now your choice of
education reveals a lot of information
to me as the receiver. So, when I see E
L, I know that you're a low type and I
must set the wage equal to L. And maybe
in parentheses, this is because B H of E
L
is zero.
What about if I see an education level
of E H? What do I conclude?
Yeah. You must be type H. You must be
type H, right? So, now this is H.
And now we have B of H given E H
equals 1.
Good.
And now
the off path wage, there's kind of a
trick that we sometimes can use.
Um
if we really want to make this an
equilibrium, we want to make it as
unappealing as possible to deviate to
any off path level of education. So, how
could we if we have flexibility here to
choose this wage, how could we choose
this wage to make deviations unappealing
for the sender?
And this maybe isn't the most realistic
equilibrium, but it's kind of a good
trick for computing equilibrium. Yeah?
Make it zero.
So, zero would would really deter
deviations, but we can't do zero. Why
can't we necessarily Why can't we do
zero? That would violate one of our
conditions, right? The problem is it
would violate our and you may not have
been here when when we went over this,
but this would violate our and I think I
just erased it, our receiver optimality
condition, right? So, off path
Bayes' rule doesn't imply any impose any
constraints in our belief. But whatever
our belief is, we still have to be
behaving optimally given our belief. And
the worst possible belief we could form
off path, worst from the standpoint of
the sender, would be to be certain that
you're a low type.
So, if we're certain you're a low type,
the wage we would charge is L.
So, you're right that a wage of zero
would be a a stronger punishment for the
sender for deviating, but it's not a
credible punishment because even if the
if the firm thinks you're always a low
ability person, they'd rather charge you
a wage of L, which is strictly positive,
than a wage of zero. But that's a uh a
helpful uh comment.
Okay?
So, here we are. Now, I think we
have some trouble because
if I'm a low type,
well, why should I choose E L and get L
if If could just Well, any other
education level I choose, I'll get L as
well. So, why don't I just deviate to
education level equals zero?
If I'm the low type,
I think deviating to equal zero looks
pretty good.
So, in fact, we immediately see a strong
constraint on what happens in a
separating equilibrium. So, first
observation, no,
EL must be zero.
If EL was not zero,
then the low type would deviate to
choose an education level of zero. And
let's think through why this is, right?
In a separating equilibrium, as a put
yourself in the position of a low type,
when you follow your equilibrium
strategy and choose EL, you're fully
revealing
to the firm that you're a low ability or
that you're a low type uh sender,
which is the worst possible thing they
can believe about you.
So, it never makes sense to pay a
positive cost to go to school only to be
believed that you're the the worst
possible type. So, if I'm going to
induce the worst possible belief about
myself, I might as well pay no cost and
not go to school at all.
Okay?
So, now EL equals zero.
Uh
good.
And let's try to kind of graph this.
Let's do our graph again, and I think
it's actually helpful
to try to represent the
sender optimality conditions on the
graph. So, let's try to do this. So,
we're going to look at a wage here.
Uh EL is going to be zero. EH is not
equal to EL, so EH has to be strictly
positive, right? So, let's just put a
guess of where EH is.
And we said that the wage is going to be
L if you deviate, if you do something
off path. So, here's L.
Here's H.
And
to here,
the wage is going to look like this.
Now,
at EH, the wage jumps to H.
So, this is an open circle.
This is a closed circle here.
And then the wage continues down.
Okay?
So, this is, if we want to be really
safe, what we would do.
But to be a little more realistic,
well,
we want to make sure that no one wants
to deviate to this high level of
education, right? But this seems like, I
mean, it it could be an equilibrium, but
it seems kind of weird to say, "If you
get a really high education, we believe
you're a low type." I mean, it's
possible, but it seems a little weird.
So, I think often what we what we'll do
is we'll choose the off path beliefs
like this,
so that actually, if you choose any
education level above EH, we'll still
pay you a wage of H. Now, why is that
okay? Well,
if you can always get an education level
of EH and get a wage of H, no one's
going to ever want to deviate beyond EH
to get the same wage that they would get
at EH. So, that, you know, going off
your comment, to be really safe, we'd
set out W E to be L, but really the
important thing is that it's L down
here. Beyond here, we can make it H and
we're not going to induce any
deviations. So, let's um
kind of be L for E
less than EH. That's kind of the
important thing.
Uh and let's
let's try to do it like this.
So, notice that this graph looks a lot
like what we had in the pooling
equilibrium, but there's a key
difference. So, like the pooling
equilibrium, if your education was too
low,
we paid you L.
But in the pooling equilibrium, if you
got to a high enough level of education,
we paid you the average ability in the
population. Now, we pay you a lot more.
We pay you H.
Because now, if I see a high level of
education, I draw a different inference.
As the receiver, I say, "Oh, if you got
a high level of education, you must be a
high type person."
So, this wage is much, much higher, and
we'll find that, not too surprisingly,
EH is going to have to be pretty high as
well to ensure that no one uh wants to
deviate.
Okay. So, we have our wage function
written down.
The wage function satisfies
uh receiver optimality by our
construction. Let's just kind of check
in words, right?
Bayes' rule applies only at these two
points.
Because at this point, at E equals zero,
that's the level of education chosen by
the low type.
We believe that you're the low type, and
we charge you a wage of L. That's great.
Here, EH, if we see that, we believe
you're a high type,
and we charge you that pay you the wage
that's optimal that belief. Everything
outside of that is off path. We had a
lot of flexibility in our choice, and we
made those choices to try to deter
deviations by the uh sender.
Okay. So, now, there's two things we
have to check.
We have to check that
the low type, so maybe I'll let's put it
over here.
The low type prefers
EL
to all other E,
E prime,
and the high type
prefers EH.
Right?
So, this is what sender optimality
means.
The type L sender in equilibrium is
choosing EL, which is zero.
And we have to check that that's better
for them than deviating to any other
level of education.
Similarly, the high type in equilibrium
is choosing EH, which is strictly
positive, and we have to check that they
prefer EH to any other level of
education.
Now, I think this can be overwhelming at
first because there's so many other
levels of education that people might
choose. But just like before,
given this wage function, I think
there's only one really candidate
deviation. I think most of the
deviations are clearly not going to be
the optimal deviation. So, let's say I'm
a low type. Here I am. I'm down here.
I'm getting a wage of L.
I see that this is what the wage
function looks like, and this is the the
choice that people actually face when
they
design their lives. Uh
what level of education might I be
tempted to deviate to?
Yeah? EH. EH, right? None of the other
deviations make sense. If I deviate to
here, I'm paying more, and I'm not
getting any wage return.
If I deviate to here, well, I am getting
a wage return, but I'm getting the same
return I could have gotten by just going
to EH. So, if I want to deviate, that's
really the key deviation.
And similarly, now let's put myself in
the position of someone of of a high
type
who's choosing EH.
They're here, and they're looking over
the graph. What is the
only kind of reasonable or tempting
deviation for the high type?
Yeah? EL.
E- exactly, EL, which in this case is
zero, right? So, EL, for the same
reason. I'm already getting a wage of H.
There's no reason for me to go to school
more. I don't like school, and it's not
going to raise my wages according to
this strategy.
If I go to less school, well, I'm going
to get a big cut in wages, but I can go
all the way down to here, and I'm still
going to get the same wage of L. So, I
might as well choose the lowest
education level that ensures that I get
uh get that wage.
So, now, let's write down these
conditions.
So, really, what we need to check is,
and sometimes I write it like this in
kind of shorthand,
so, what I mean by this is
this, I say, this means type H prefers.
This is a weak, maybe I'll say something
like this. So, what I need to check is
if I'm type H, I prefer choosing uh an
education level of EH to an education
level of EL.
Of course, I have to prefer it to any
other education level, but we said this
is really the deviation I'm tempted by.
And then we have to check if I'm a low
type L, I weakly prefer my own education
level EL to deviating to the education
level EH.
Now, in general, I have to worry about
every other deviation, but because of
the special structure we've used uh when
we define this wage function, we only
have to check these two conditions.
Okay? So, let's just write this out
uh in math.
If I'm a high type and I choose EH, then
I'm going to get a wage of H,
but then I'm going to have to pay
1 over H EH squared.
Maybe let's go down here. What if I'm a
low type? Uh no, we'll just go through
it.
Now, if I deviate to EL,
well, then I get L.
Maybe I'll write it out. It's 1 over H
EL squared,
but that's just L because EL is zero.
And I think as usual,
let's simplify this little bit.
That is
H minus L
is greater than or equal to
And this has the same interpretation,
right? Now, the wage premium is
different in the separating equilibrium.
The wage premium is now H minus L.
And what this condition says is the wage
premium is higher than the cost of
education for the high type.
So, going to college and getting an
education of EH is worth it for the high
type because their cost of doing that is
weekly smaller than the wage premium
they'll get from doing that.
Now let's look at the same condition for
the low type.
So for the low type, well, if they
choose their equilibrium education level
of zero, they don't pay anything and
they get a wage of L.
So we get and again maybe I'll
uh it's L, but if we really write it
out, it's it's this, right?
Where this just second term disappears
uh because EL is zero.
And this has to be
greater than or equal to what? Well, if
they deviate and choose a high level of
education, they're going to get the wage
H, but then they have to pay 1 over L EH
squared.
And again, let's uh let's simplify.
And what does this say in words?
Can we interpret this uh yeah? The wage
premium is
um smaller than the cost of
I guess
getting education EH for uh the low
type. For the low type, exactly. So and
this is if you recall, it's sort of
similar when we talked about the essay
problem last week and we said the cost
of the essay has to be uh cheap enough
that the excited students take it, but
expensive enough that the less excited
students take it. That's exactly what's
going on here. In order to sustain a
separating equilibrium, because it's a
separating equilibrium, the wage premium
is going to be H minus L because high
education fully reveals your high type,
low education fully reveals your low
type. So that So that defines the fact
that it's a separating equilibrium
defines what the wage premium is going
to be.
But then we have to check that it's
actually optimal for each type to follow
what they're supposed to do uh in this
equilibrium.
The high type people are supposed to get
educated.
So the level of education EH must be low
enough
that it's worth it for high ability or
high type people to choose to get that
education because the wage premium
outweighs the cost for those types.
At the same time, the level of education
must be high enough. If it was too low,
then even the low types would also
choose that education and we would no
longer have a separating equilibrium. So
the level of education must at the same
time be high enough that for the low
types it's not worth uh going to
education, uh going to school because
the cost exceeds the wage premium that
they get.
And if we do this, we can get a formula
for what EH has to be, right? So maybe
this is helpful. Let's pull the H over
here and what we get is EH
needs to be between H
H minus L.
And it has to be above
And let's just check that this works.
Well,
because L is smaller than H, this
inequality uh
does indeed is indeed satisfied for a
certain range of of types.
Uh I think it's
helpful to compare.
So this is
let's compare what happened
in the uh
pooling equilibrium. So this is
separating.
So in separating, the low types got no
education and the high types got EH.
In the pooling equilibrium, both types
got E star
and E star satisfied the following
property.
So how do these compare?
If we look at these
bounds,
how does the pooling
equilibrium compare? How does E star
compare to EH if you look at these
inequalities?
Let's look, right?
Mu is an average between H and L, right?
So mu is certainly smaller than H.
So this
is smaller than this.
So we see a fundamental difference
between the two kinds of equilibria.
In the separating equilibrium, the low
types get no education and the high
types get a lot of education.
In the pooling equilibrium, both types
get this lower intermediate level of
education that's E star is must be
strictly lower than EH. So we sort of
have two worlds, right? We have one
world and they're both equilibria.
There's one world where getting educated
conveys a lot of benefits
and people or I should say getting very
highly educated conveys a lot of
benefits. People pay a huge cost, the
high types pay a huge cost to get highly
educated and they get a huge uh return.
There's also another equilibrium we
could be in where people don't get as
much as educated. There's not a huge
benefit to education, but everyone gets
it.
And I think these actually are kind of
consistent with um you might imagine in
different countries we might kind of
reach different equilibria where
education has a different role um in
society.
Um both of these are consistent. It's
everyone's behaving optimally given what
everyone else is doing, uh but here the
beliefs that the market forms about your
education in this equilibrium are
different. Sorry, the beliefs the market
forms about your ability given your
education are different than the beliefs
the market forms in this equilibrium and
then people are responding accordingly.
And it's and it's mutually consistent in
each case.
Let me
maybe just do one final thing. I think
it's sometimes helpful
to visualize these constraints
geometrically. So I've written out the
constraint for the separating
equilibrium up here, but I want to try
to to visualize this.
And I think a good way
to
visualize this is to say, well, we want
to look at something that is called an
indifference curve. And if you studied
other economics classes, you would have
seen this.
What we want to say is, well, we're in
the plane here where the horizontal axis
is your level of education and the
vertical axis is your wage.
And we want to ask, what are the pairs
of wage
and education
that give you the same utility?
Well, let's write this the formula down.
So for the low type
or for type T,
an indifference curve would have the
form, say, U bar
equals wage minus 1 over T
E squared.
So what I'm saying is
I want to look at all the pairs WE that
give type T the utility U bar.
And if I solve if I write this out, what
I get is W equals U bar plus
1 over T
E squared.
So what this tells me is W is going to
be a an increasing quadratic function of
E squared. So let's try to write this
down. It might look something like this.
What this indicates is
the set What I'm saying is if I moved
along this curve,
the utility that I would get, say I'm
the low type here,
is the same along this curve.
Because if I move a little bit to the
right along this curve, I'm getting more
educated, that's more costly, but my
wage is also increasing at just the
right rate to ensure that my utility
stays constant.
And then we could draw another utility
curve by shifting the value of U bar, we
could draw another utility curve like
this.
And another one like this.
So what this says is these all give me
the same utility. These all give me the
same utility, but that utility is going
to be higher than this utility. And
similarly, these all give me the same
utility, but a higher utility still than
the previous case.
Good.
Now,
let's say these are the indifference
curves
for the low types.
Now I want to draw the indifference
curves for the high types.
And this is tricky. Are the high types
indifference curves going to be steeper
than the low type or shallower than the
low type?
This is We could do the algebra, but I
think it's good to kind of think it
through.
So they're also going to be quadratic.
They're going to have a similar
shape.
Not shallower or steeper? What do you
think?
Have a half chance?
Well, let's think it through. What does
this curves mean? It tells me
if I get this much more education,
I have to get paid this much more to
compensate me for it and keep me
indifferent.
So does a high type need to be
compensated more or less
for the same level of education?
More.
Actually less because a high type finds
education less costly.
So if I'm really good at school
and I do it go to school a little bit
more, I don't need to get paid too much
more to keep me indifferent, right? If
I'm really good at school, I can go to
school for 20 years and you just need to
pay me a little bit, right? So here I'm
going to get
curves like
say something like this.
Uh no, these should not intersect,
sorry.
Something like
something like that.
Let me forget this last one.
So these are the indifference curves for
the high types.
And in fact, using these curves, we can
exactly represent graphically the levels
of education that could support a
separating equilibrium. So, it's exactly
going to be
this range here. Do I have
And let's just see it in words, right?
This dotted line here
is the indifference curve that passes
through zero L for the low type.
So, these are the wage education level
pairs that make the low type indifferent
with zero L, with no education and a
wage of L.
So, if I want to have a separating
equilibrium,
I better make this EH high enough that
the low type doesn't want to deviate to
EH. And that precisely means EH has to
be farther to the right of this point.
Because if EH is over here, that tells
me the low type strictly prefers to get
no education and a wage of L than to get
this level of education and a wage of H.
On the other hand,
the high type must weakly prefer to get
high education than no education.
Uh
I misconstrued this.
It's going to go all the way over to
here. Sorry.
So, the high type's indifference curve
that passes through zero L
goes
all the way up to here.
So, just to maybe go through it one last
time, let's make sure we understand.
If I could get a level of education here
and get paid a wage of H, that would be
better than no education and a wage of L
for both high and low types.
So, that couldn't be part of a
separating equilibrium.
If I chose EH to be way over here, then
getting this level of education and a
wage of H would be worse than zero L for
both types. The only way I can have a
separating equilibrium is if I lie
exactly in this range. And if I lie in
that range, I ensure that this
additional education is worth it for the
high type, but not worth it for the low
type.
And I'm The crucial point here is I'm
looking at the indifference curves that
pass through the point zero L.
So, these are considering the pairs of
education and wages that So, let me just
as I'm concluding, let me say say it
smoothly in in words one last time.
These are the pairs of wages and
education that make the high type
indifferent with this point. And these
are the pairs of education and wages
that make the high type indifferent that
make the low type indifferent with this
point. And everything in between is
going to ensure that the high type finds
it worth it to get educated and the low
type finds it not worth it. Uh we did
the algebra, but it's just good to see
the graph. And I think on the problem
set, you'll be asked to uh to illustrate
this graphically.